you know you get so used now to
celebrities posting things that they
just sort of like go by I see different
celebrities doing things and I check it
out every now and now you say okay well
it all starts to blending together and
then you put out this gif recently that
a lot of people paid attention to and
are you okay with us showing this right
now yeah okay all right well just tell
me what's look at it first and then tell
us what's that's you okay there you go
[Applause]
I'm obsessed with these cat underwear
they're super cute a little flawed I
don't have a lot of friends to tell me
like it's fine to wear a cat underwire
you know it's showing it might be but
but first of all surprising not yeah my
wife comes in him on the computer and
then in August
no it was very funny and silly whimsical
flirty yeah yeah posted I did have
second thoughts like oh my god I'm
wearing [ __ ] underwear I think this is
so creepy I'm 40 and then my son comes
back from his dad and he's like I saw
you on Instagram yeah but I mean my son
loves cats
yeah wait so your son saw it that's so
crazy
and I just said I saw it on Instagram I
know his dad he said dad was flipping
through Instagram and I said oh well did
he like it
yes my son my son came to me about I
would say like about a month ago he came
to me he said dad what's pornography and
I was like oh well yeah let me show you
I've got hours of it no he said what's
pornography and I said oh well you must
have heard that word at school and we're
gonna talk about it as hope they talk
where did you hear the word and he said
on a Simpsons episode that you wrote
anyway he's in jail
you